yeah a new case of sequelitis you hate
to see it but it happens
[Music]
I really liked and loved by me Shazam
Billy Batson and his siblings The Rock
and the powers of Shazam otherwise known
as powers of gods they're out there
saving people but not so gracefully
doing so a lot of collateral damage but
now these goddesses known as the
daughters of Kronos they've shown up
they don't like humans too much so all
right they're gonna cause problems new
movie now what I liked about this movie
I got to give a special shout out to
Jack Dylan Grazer I felt he was the
emotional center of the entire film he's
always been a talented kid this movie is
a testament to that I felt he really
brought it but it is also a testament to
the fact that the emotional center of a
movie like this is when they're not
superheroes they're just normal kids and
that also feeds into what I appreciate
about Asher Angel playing Billy Batson
in this film because in the previous
film the contrast between Billy Batson
Asher Angel and how Zachary Levi acted
it was too vast they didn't feel like
the same person that Gap that contrast
it's still there but you can tell Asher
Angel is trying his best to act like
Zach Levi more in this film than he did
in the previous film it's like they
listened to the fan feedback they
proceed accordingly I appreciate that
weird thing is Billy Batson is largely
absent in this film he's in it but not
as much as you'd think not as much as
the previous film most of the time when
you see the character he's Shazam he's
Zachary Levi he's the adult superhero
version there are even scenes where he
and his Shazam fam they're all hanging
out in their Shazam cave and they're
they're in their superhero Shazam well I
guess it's not outfits they're in their
adult superhero forms but they're just
planning and hanging out no reason to be
and I felt that did cost the movie
Something the emotional center point of
the characters is best seen when their
kids you know when they're in their
youthful form and they're dealing with
their problems when they're in their
Shazam form for most of the movie it
loses a bit of that contrast it feels
less like their kids who get to become
superheroes and more like their god-like
superheroes who sometimes become kids
and that was actually the positive part
of the review because the rest of the
movie was just
it was generic superhero stuff you don't
really have cool or relatable villains
in this movie granted you could make the
villains people don't really know or
care about you can make them cool in the
movie but they just didn't generally
love Helen Mirren and Lucy Liu but they
came across as generic 2004 comic book
movie villains dropped in 2023. from
there the rest of the movie is bringing
back characters they killed off in the
previous movie that they want to bring
back for this movie also it's a flowing
ebb of have their powers they don't
because they have to Nerf the Shazam fam
otherwise
the baddies to be taken out pretty
quickly that's what I mean when I say
sequelitis not like this movie was
planned from the first one if it was
don't tell me it was let me blissfully
believe that the mess of a sequel came
about because of the success of the
first movie and it wasn't planned I used
the word generic because it's the only
word to describe my general feeling that
this movie left me with generic villain
summon a whole horde of generic CGI
monsters for the last act and I didn't
care didn't care about the CGI monsters
didn't care about the villains that
summoned them and there are some
emotional moments in this movie even
near the end I did appreciate they were
there I was just bored by the time I saw
them now I do appreciate the fact this
movie doesn't rely on the general dceu
which is now non-existent but it doesn't
rely on the universe to pitch and sell
the movie it operates how I feel a comic
book movie should operate operate within
your own contained story know that as
part of a larger universe as a whole
have a couple Easter eggs in there that
reminds the odd audience that is part of
that but they don't have to watch every
TV show movie it doesn't feel like
homework I did appreciate Shazam for
that granted there is that overall
feeling when a couple of tie-ins are
referenced and are shown you're like
what's the point luckily these moments
don't plague the film too badly but you
can't help but notice you can't help but
think about it you can't help but when
you see these moments think to yourself
what is the point look in the end Shazam
Fury of the Gods as someone who loved
the first shazam movie I was really
disappointed with this sequel as a movie
that deals largely with magic it was
surprisingly devoid of it it almost
feels like they didn't know what made
the first shazam movie special and click
with audiences who liked it so they were
just grasping at straws for the sequel
you know what's funny is I don't even
hate this movie it sounds like I do but
I don't it's I kind of nothing
I'm not gonna remember not in T minus
one day yep already forgot all right so
Shazam Fury of the gods have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]